en fait c'est c'est uneillistration de
Monsieur monsieur Macron qui n'aime pas
la France qui dit qu'il a pas le
française qui crache sur les pieds noirs
qui crache sur les rapatriés qui pointe
du Doig le gouvernement français en
disant qu'il a commis des crimes contre
l'uminité au moment de la guerre
d'Algérie moi ce type là n'aime pas la
France clairement mais il y a un côté il
y a d'un côté il y a deux candidats il y
a la candidate qui hier soir était un
NOMON au cœur de la ralité qui ce matin
était sur un marché dans le Pas de calé
et puis il y a Monsieur et puis a
Monsieur Macron qui lui aussi va devoir
élargir son discours ça pour rembl dans
our dei Faour de Paris et aain de fte à
la parce s fermé c'est ça je crois que
le masque est enain de tomber vous saz
les Français sont agacés est méprisant
il est arrogant ce monsieur ce monsieur
n'aime pas la France Ilim pas la France
il n pas le peuple français il sa lui
rendre croyez-moi le SO du second
tour